who eg am i number one rapper North
Korea Kim Jong notice I'm not laughs I
mean was good I am the number one rapper
in North Korea like I am the only repla
in North Korea I'm going to wrap today
you see with the stereotype oh he's a
number one he's a producer in u.s. of
America
what everybody it's a germ base from the
stereotypes I'm the white member were in
the booth excuse me we're in the studio
we got the booth in the background we
got Kim Jong Killa
she's gonna bless the mic today what's
up y'all this is John Street
I'm part of the stereotypes I am the
yellow one of the group today I'm super
excited we have Kim Jong ìlet in the
booth
he's about to spit some hot fire what's
going on everyone raivo from the
stereotypes were in with him something
Kim jong-il Kim jong-il oh we're in with
him John came and I'm super excited I
just want to see what you don't see when
it comes with a hurt he's super talented
this is undoubtedly one of the worst
sessions I've ever been in unfortunately
this man is crazy he's horrible music is
playing he's rapping music stops playing
he's rapping keeps touching me or not
touching me but like it just keeps
touching my skin on my hair or something
[Applause]
[Music]
he's ahead feel like that crow he said
good if I want the tachi sideshow to
I'll call your kids you know you look
good
nice a bit crow yeah you know that what
they're crooks agree so yeah this is
what we use like the okay what's this
one Africa no its prey okay pickle is
nice what nose is a bomb my pickup can i
crush this one dog mine my name is Ray
peacock ray Arica okay every time that
he has something to say he always comes
and talks to me about it so I'm not
really sure what that's about China
China China good men he's a good man he
reminds me of my mother
look just like my mother mr. GaN China
but that is dumb money
my name is not China what's this China I
know anything robot is a huge I know
China was there no China time China my
name's John he keeps ignoring me he cuts
me off every single time I say anything
okay y'all right that's okay I real
could be said okay you to China you go
away George Bush II know so all right so
you're gonna catch the beat right there
that's the hook
[Music]
nobody's trying to help you wanna know
this all taki okay no but okay
listen to my idea this uses you help
mine it's okay you have a no night no
sounded like a Georgia boy she I said I
had to use the bathroom and he cut me
off
he raced me down the hallway to the
bathroom not me use the bathroom
sessions done thank God we don't have
them booked for the next never hopefully
he said my English is perfect
don't subtitle my English he's perfect
you're perfect be perfect to get it he
killed four thousand babies for that
Jamie said I'm scared of him yeah yo
[Music]
[Music]
okay yeah that's the funny JC my best
friend my best friend Kyle is my best
friend
I check the morning notice on my lap I
mean what's good what's going on YouTube
it's your boy David's over here and
today we had some special guests in the
skit so I'm letting go ahead do their
thing did you do some selves people
mouths what's up I'm ray row John Street
I'm germ beets we are the stereotypes in
your face that's right they're my best
friends uh fellas bring it in let's do
this again bring you know bring you know
are you gonna do that to me you know
what
I'll give you mom soup the other day and
you too huh dead a little awkward
hey what's up okay bring it bring it
okay I ain't gonna say [ __ ] to you cuz
you kind of buff so um keep on walking
so I you know he's a telephone so some
might kill upon